[? HEATH ROE: ?] Hello, my
name is Heath [? Roe, ?]
I'm Research Operations Manager
for the Insights Lab at Google,
and I want to thank you for
joining us today for Cory
Doctorow.
Cory Doctorow is a science
fiction author, activist,
journalist, and blogger,
co-editor of Boing Boing
and author of many books,
including the nonfiction
business book,
"Information Doesn't
Want To Be Free,"
the young adult
novel, "Little Brother," and
his newest novel, "Walkaway."
He works for the Electronic
Frontier Foundation,
is an MIT Media Lab
research affiliate,
serves as a visiting professor
of computer science at Open
University, and co-founded
the UK Open Rights Group.
Born in Toronto, Canada, Cory
now lives in Los Angeles--
Burbank, to be specific.
He's here today to read from
and talk about "Walkaway,"
which has been described as
an optimistic disaster novel.
I introduce to
you, Cory Doctorow.
CORY DOCTOROW: Thanks, Heath.
Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I have a long and, largely,
fruitful association
with this firm.
I remember going to
the first Christmas
party at what used to be
the SGI offices, and going,
I remember when these
were the SGI offices.
So I've been around the
Googles for a long time,
but I've never been to this one.
You have very nice digs.
I like your weird, Guggy
architecture out front.
I'm going to read
to you a little bit
from this novel,
if I can figure out
where my standard reading is.
I was on a 35-city
book tour where
I did this reading
at least once a day,
and was able to find the
section of the book like that.
[SNAP] And you can tell
I'm out of practice, now,
because I had to do
that for a second.
I'm going to read to you
a little bit from the book
and then, I will answer
any questions you have.
And then, we can move on
to the ritual defacement
of books with sharpies.
So that's the order
of service, here.
The section I'm going to
read from chapter two.
It's called, "You All
Meet in a Tavern."
"Sundays at the Belt and
Braces were the busiest,
and there was always
competition for the best jobs.
The first person through
the door hit the lights
and checked the infographics.
These were easy enough
to read that anyone can
make sense of them, even noobs.
But Limpopo was no noob.
She had more commits
into the Belt and Braces
firmware than anyone, an
order of magnitude lead
over the rest.
It was technically in poor taste
for her to count her commits,
let alone keep a tally.
In a gift economy, you
gave without keeping score,
because keeping score implied
an expectation of reward.
If you did something
for reward, it
was an investment, not a gift.
In theory, Limpopo agreed.
In practice, it was
so easy to keep score,
the leaderboard
was so satisfying
that she couldn't help herself.
She wasn't proud
of this, mostly.
But this Sunday, first through
the door the Belt and Braces,
alone in the big common
room with its aligned rows
of tables and chairs, all the
infographic showing nominal,
she felt proud.
She patted the wall with
a perverse, unacceptable
proprietary air.
She'd helped build
the Belt and Braces,
scavenging the
Badlands for the parts
its drone outriders
had identified
for its construction.
It was the project she'd
found her walkaway with,
the thing uppermost in her
mind when she'd looked around
the Badlands, set down her pack,
emptied her pockets of anything
worth stealing, put
extra underwear in a bag,
and walked out into
the Niagara escarpment,
past the invisible line
separating civilization from
no-man's-land, out of the world
as it was and into the world
as it could be.
The codebase had originated
with the UN High Commission
on Refugees and had been
field-trialed a lot.
You told it the building
you wanted, gave it
a scavenging range, and
it directed its drones
to inventory anything nearby,
scanning multi-band, doing
deep database scrapes
against urban planning
and building-code sources
to identify usable blocks
for whatever you were making.
This was turned into a scavenger
hunt inventory, and refugees
or aid workers, or,
in shameful incidents,
the trafficked juveniles
slaves, fanned out
to retrieve the
pieces the building
needed to conjure
itself into existence.
These flowed onto the job site.
The building tracked
and configured them,
a continuously refactored
critical path for its
build plan that
factored in the skill
levels of the workers or the
robots on-site at any moment.
The effect was something
like magic and something
like ritual humiliation.
If you installed
something wrong,
the system tried to find
a way to work around
your stupid mistake.
Failing that, the system
buzzed your haptics
with rising intensity.
And if you ignored them, it
tried optical and even audible.
If you squelched
that, it started
telling the other humans
that something was amiss
and instructed them to fix it.
There had been a lot of
A/B splitting of this.
It was there in the codebase
and the unit-tests for anyone
to review, and the most
successful strategy
the buildings had found
for correcting humans
was to pretend that
they didn't exist.
If you planted a piece
of structural steel
in a way the building
really couldn't work with
and ignored the rising
chorus of warnings,
someone else would
be told that there
was a piece of
"misaligned" material
and tasked to it,
with high urgency.
It was the same error
the buildings generated
if something slipped,
and it didn't
assume that a human
being had fucked up
through malice or incompetence.
The initial theory
had been that an error
without a responsible
party would be more
socially graceful.
People doubled down
on their mistakes,
especially when they
were embarrassed
in front of their peers.
The name-and-shame
alternate versions
had shown that
hot-cheeked fierce denial
was the biggest impediment
to standing up a building.
So if you fucked
up, soon someone
would turn up with a
[INAUDIBLE] or a forklift
or a screwdriver
and a job ticket
to unfuck the thing that
you were percussively
maintaining into submission.
You could pretend that you
were doing the same job
as the new guy, part
of the solution instead
of the problem's cause.
This like you save face so
that you wouldn't insist
that you were doing it
right and the building's
stupid instructions,
and everything else
in the universe, was wrong.
Reality was chewily weirder
in a way that Limpopo loved.
It turned out that if you are
dispatched to defubar something
and found someone
who was obviously
the source of the enfubarage,
you could completely
tell that that structural
steel was not three degrees off
true because of slippage.
It was three degrees off
true because some dipshit
flubbed it.
What's more, Senor Dipshit
knew that you knew that he was
at fault. But the fact that the
trouble ticket read urgent--
retrue structural member minus
three degrees at 120 degrees
north-northeast,
and not, urgent--
retrue structural member minus
3 degrees and 120 degrees
north-northeast because
some dipshit can't follow
instructions, let both of you
do this mannered kabuki in which
you operated in the third
person passive voice--
the beam has become off-true,
not, you fucked up the beam.
That pretense-- the researchers
called it networked social
disattention, but everyone else
called it the how did that get
there affect--
had been a vital shift in the
UNHCR's distributed shelter
initiative.
Prior to that, it had all
been gamified to fuckery,
with leaderboards for the most
correct installs and the best
looters.
Test builds were marred by angry
confrontations and fistfights.
Even this could be a
virtue, since every build
would figure into a
two or three subgroups,
each putting up
their own buildings.
It was three for
the price of one.
Inevitably, these
forked-off projects
would be less ambitious
than the original plan.
So early sites had a
characteristic look--
a wide, flat, low building,
the first three stories
of something that had been
planned for 10 before half
the workers had quit.
At 100 meters away,
three more buildings,
each half the size of
the first, representing
the forked and reforked
buildings-revenge
built by alienated splitters.
Some sites had Fibonacci
spirals of ever-smaller forks,
terminating in a single
hostility-radiating, hate-built
Wendy house.
The buildings made the leap from
the UNHCR repo to the walkways
and mutated into
innumerable variations
on the clinics-school-shelter
refugee trinity.
The Belt and Braces was the
first tavern ever attempted.
Layouts for restaurant
Kitchens weren't
far off from camp kitchens,
and big commons spaces
were easy enough, but the
actual zeitgeist of the thing
was substantially different,
tweaked in 1,000 different ways
so that you would never
walk into it and say,
huh, this is a refugee
residence that's been
converted into a restaurant.
And you'd also never
mistake the Belt and Braces
for a normal restaurant.
Its major feature was the
projection-mapped lighting
that painted surfaces and
items throughout its interior
with subtle red-green tones
indicating where something
needed human attention.
This was also UNHCR
playbook, but again, there
was a world of difference
between dishing up
MREs to climate
refuse and serving
fancy dry-ice cocktails made
from wet-printers and powdered
alcohol.
No refugee camp ever went
through quite so many cocktail
parasols and perfect-knots
swizzle sticks.
On an average day,
the Belt and Braces
served a couple
of hundred people.
On Sundays, it
was more like 500.
The influx of noobs
brought scouts
for talent, sexual partners,
bandmates, playmates,
and, of course, victims.
Being the first one
through the door
meant that Limpopo would
get to play maitre d'.
The assays showed that last
night's beer had come up well.
The hydrogen cells
were running 45%,
which would run the Belt and
Braces for two weeks flat out.
The eggbeaters on the roof
had been running hard,
electrolyzing waste
water and pumping
cracked hydrogen in the cells.
There were 50 cells in the
basement, harvested out
of abandoned jets the
drones had spotted.
The jets hadn't been
airworthy for a long time,
but had yielded
quantities of materiel
for the Belt and Braces,
including dozens of benches
made from their seats.
The hard-wearing
upholstery had come clean,
its dirt-shedding
surfaces revealing designs
with each wipe of their rags
like re-appearing disappearing
ink.
But the hydrogen cells had
been the biggest find of all,
and without them,
the Belt and Braces
would have been very
different, prone to shortages
and brownouts.
Limpopo fretted that
they'd be stolen.
It took all her self-control
not to install surveillanceware
around all the utility hatches.
The pre-prep stuff on
the larders showed green,
but she still made a point of
personally sniffing the cheese
cultures and prodding the dough
through its kneading film.
The sauce precursors
smelled tasty
and the ice cream maker
hummed as it lazily
aerated the frozen cream.
She called for coffium
and sat skewered
on a beam of light in
the middle of the commons
as the delicious, fruity, musky
aroma wafted into the room.
The first cup of coffium
danced hot in her mouth,
and its early-onset ingredients
percolated into her bloodstream
through the mucous
membranes under her tongue.
Her fingertips
and scalp tingled,
and she closed her eyes
to enjoy the effects
the second-wave
substances brought on
as her gut started to work.
Her hearing became preternatural
and the big muscles
in her quads and pecs and
shoulders got a fiery feeling,
like dancing while
standing still.
She took another deep
draft and closed her eyes.
And when she opened them
again, she had company.
They were such
obvious noobs, they
could have come from
central casting.
Worse, they were shleppers,
their heavy outsized packs,
many-pocketed trekking
coats, and cargo pants
stuffed to bulging.
They looked overinflated.
Shleppers were neurotic
and probably destined
to walk back within
weeks, leaving
behind lingering interpersonal
upfuckedness in their wake.
Limpopo had gone walkaway
the right way, with nothing
more than clean underwear, which
turned out to be superfluous.
She tried not to prejudge
these three, especially
in that giddy first five
minutes of her coffium buzz.
She didn't want him
harsh her mellow.
"Welcome to the B and B!"
she shouted, louder
than intended.
They flinched and then rallied.
"Hi, there," the girl
said, and walked forward.
Her clothes were beautiful,
bias-cut and contrast stitched.
Limpopo immediately
coveted them.
She'd pull the girl's images
from the archives later
and decompose the patterns
and run a set for herself.
She'd be the envy of all who saw
her until the design propagated
and became old news.
"Sorry to just walk in, but
we heard--" "You heard right."
Limpopo's voice was quieter,
but still too shouty.
Either the coffium
had to burn down
so she could control
her affect, or she
needed to drink a lot more so
she could stop giving a shit.
She thumped the refill zone and
put her cup under the nozzle.
"Open to everyone,
all day, every day.
But Sundays are special,
our way of saying hello
to our new neighbors and
getting to know them.
I'm Limpopo.
What do you want to be called?"
The phrasing was particular
to the walkaways,
an explicit invitation
to remake yourself.
It was the height of
walkaway sophistication
to greet people with it, and
Limpopo used it deliberately
on these three
because she could tell
that they were tightly wound.
The shorter of the two
guys, with a scruffy
kinked beard and a stubbly
shaved head stuck his hand out.
"I'm Gizmo von Puddleducks."
This is Zombie
McDingleberry and Etcetera."
The other two rolled their eyes.
"Thank you, Gizmo,
but actually, you
can call me Stable
Strategies," the girl said.
The other guy, tall
but hunched over
with an owlish expression and
exhaustion lines in his face,
sighed.
"You might as well
call me Etcetera.
Thanks, Herr von Puddleducks."
"Very pleased to
meet," Limpopo said.
"Why don't you put your
stuff down and grab a seat,
and I'll get you some coffium."
so that's the reading.
So "Walkaway," it's an
optimistic disaster novel.
That's what I call it.
And the thesis underlying
it is that you are not
a pessimistic person if you
assume something will go wrong
with a system.
Engineers who design
systems on the assumption
that nothing will ever go
critically wrong with them
don't make good systems.
They build the Titanic.
And so optimism
is not the belief
that nothing will go wrong.
Optimism is the belief
that we can design systems
that coast to a gentle
stop when they go wrong,
instead of exploding
and showering
all the people around them
with white hot shrapnel.
And it's the belief that once
they've posted to a stop,
we can get them started again.
And one of the initial
impetuses for writing this book
was another book, a history
book by a woman named
Rebecca Solnit.
She's best known for coining
the term mansplaining.
But she came to do that
because she's an historian.
And she had written a
very well-regarded history
book that had been written
up in "The New Yorker,"
and she was at a party at, I
think Park City at Sundance
or something, and she met
this millionaire blowhard who
started telling
her about this book
that he'd read a review
of in "The New Yorker,"
and he was getting it wrong.
It was her book.
And she kept saying,
I wrote that book.
And he would just continue to
talk about what the book was
about and what its thesis was,
and she kept saying, no, I
wrote that book.
And that's how she came to
coin the term mansplaining.
But the book that I'd read
that really impressed me--
all of her books
are very impressive.
The one that really
impressed me is a book
called "A Paradise
Built in Hell,"
and it's a very closely
researched history
of disasters, starting with the
1906 San Francisco earthquake,
and ending around
the Haiti earthquake.
And it explores the
gap between the way
that people on the
ground in disasters
experience them,
the way that people
who are a little distant from
the disaster experience them,
and then the way that we
remember them in hindsight.
And her thesis is
that disasters,
although we often
depict them in the press
and think about them as
being the moment at which
the shackles of politesse
and decency are taken off,
and you know, you run over
to your neighbor's house
and kill them, that
actually, disasters
are experienced
by the people who
lived through them as the moment
when, like, the refrigerator
hum of background
petty grievance stops
and you realize
that you have more
in common with the
people across the road
than you have
differential from them.
And you go and start
digging through the rubble
to rescue them, and
everyone pitches in.
And that people
often, in retrospect
remember disasters as
a very stressful time,
but as a time when their
faith in humanity was renewed.
But in between those
two things, this thing
that we remember in hindsight or
assume a priori about disasters
and the way people
lived through disasters,
is a third phenomenon, something
called elite panic, which
is the belief of the wealthy,
that when the lights go out,
the poor come in to get them.
And the way that that
manifests is often
with a kind of
preemptive strike to keep
the civil order that they know
will degenerate in the moment.
And that this interferes
really greatly
with the ability of people to
get the machine started again.
And the best example
of it from the book--
it's full of great
examples, but the one
that's most sort of
picture-perfect of this
is that after the
1906 earthquake,
General Funston marched his
troops out of the Presidio,
convinced of two
things, both of which
he was totally wrong about.
The first was that
he understood enough
about controlled demolition
to build fire breaks,
and the second was that after
he'd set fire to San Francisco,
that he couldn't
let poor people back
into the mission to
fight the fires that he'd
started because they'd loot.
And that's how he
came to burn down
a quarter of San Francisco.
And you know, you
really couldn't
ask for a better example of how
the conviction that the poors
are coming for you,
and an unwillingness
to trust people to recover
from their own disaster,
turns disaster into catastrophe.
And I think some of
the blame for this,
at least in the
contemporary era,
can be placed at the feet
of pulp fiction, which
is a place where I'm
very comfortable to be.
I'm a pulp science
fiction writer.
I write stories where the
plot is front and center.
William Gibson gave
this great interview
to "The Paris Review" a couple
of years ago, where they said,
like, do you ever meet
snooty literary professors
who turn their nose
up at you because you
write science fiction?
He says, yeah, but
when that happens,
I just remind myself
that I'm a pulp
writer, a lineal descendant
of Dashiell Hammett.
By God, I can plot my fucking
wheel-- my fucking tractor has
wheels on it, right?
And I'm a pulp writer
and I love pulp stories.
And in a pulp story, you
always put the plot first.
And you can ask the reader
to suspend their disbelief
in order to advance the plot.
So we're all familiar
with this and the genre
of techno-thrillers, right?
In techno-thrillers,
anytime a computer
can do something
routinely that would
make the plot less
interesting, we just
pretend the computer
can't do it.
And anytime there's something
that computers absolutely
can't do, but it'd be great
for the plot if they could,
we just pretend they can.
And that kind of, like,
techno-metaphoric fiction
is a motif in a genre who's
central figure is the computer.
And yet computers are like
the least important thing
to how that genre works.
And I think in pulp fiction,
we like to get a twofer out
of disasters.
We like to say,
well, why do we have
to choose between man versus
nature and man versus man?
Can't we have man versus
nature versus man?
Can't the earthquake knock
your building down, and then
your neighbors come
over to eat you?
Right, because that does
make for an exciting plot.
I mean, I like "The
Walking Dead," too.
But the reality is that
that's not how it plays.
And I wrote this novel,
"Little Brother," 10 years ago,
in which I kind of took as my
central operating constraint
to write a story in which the
actual theoretical constraints
and capabilities of computers
would be the constraints
and capabilities of the plot.
And it turned out
that far from making
the story less interesting,
it gave it longevity, right?
I wrote a story about
contemporary technology
in 2006-- it was
published in 2008--
that's still read today.
Edward Snowden took a copy
of the sequel with him
when he went on the run.
It's taught at the West
Point Cyber Institute
in their Digital
Insurgency program,
and at the Air Force Academy.
And the reason that
book still chimes today
is not because I'm a fortune
teller who knew how computers
would work in 10 years.
It's because the underlying
theory of computers
doesn't move that quickly.
Things that turn on things like
Turing completeness and Von
Neumann architectures and the
theoretical limits of crypto,
those are things that
retain their longevity.
And in the same way,
I thought, well,
what would happen if I
wrote a disaster novel where
instead of shelving the
inconvenient truth that people
are mostly OK, and mostly
want to pitch in and help
their neighbors, I made that
the central tenant of the plot,
and made the conflict not
that your neighbors are
total bastards, but that
it's possible for people
who like and even
love each other,
and who have the same goal about
getting the machine started
again, to have a totally
irreconcilable difference
about how to serve that goal.
And the fights you
have with the people
you like and even love, they
are way more dramatic and harder
to recover from
than the fights you
have with your mere enemies.
Like, win the argument over
the Christmas dinner table
and you'll never be
invited back again, right?
It's the only thing more
traumatic than losing it.
And so I wrote this novel,
it's done really well.
It's been out since
April, so now I
have a little bit of data on it.
It's sold really well on a
bunch of bestseller lists.
It's just been sold
into France and Germany
and a bunch of other markets.
And I think that some of this is
attributable to this underlying
idea.
And more importantly,
I think it's
a vision that, rather than
being optimistic or pessimistic,
is hopeful.
And I think of being hopeful
as a fundamentally computer
science way of
looking at problems.
So in computer science, we
often have intractable problems,
problems that scale
in geometric time,
problems whose terrain
can't be fully known,
or whose terrain is dynamic
and changes during the course
of the problem solution.
And in those instances,
we deploy things
like hill climbing,
where we don't
know how to get from A
to Z, and even if we did,
computing A to Z would be
a complete waste of time
because by the time we got
to B, the remaining terrain
would have reconfigured itself.
This is why the
casualty of every battle
is the plan of attack.
And so instead we
have hill climbing,
which basically says, if
you can think of one way
to materially improve your
situation apropo the problem,
take that step.
Resurveil the landscape
immediately around you
and see if there's another
step that suggests itself.
And yeah, it can get
mired in local optima,
but it's the way that we solve
these really hard intractable
problems.
And hope is the
belief not that you
know how to solve your
problem, but that there
is a thing you can do
that will materially
improve your situation.
And that from that new vantage,
there'll be another step
you can take.
It's why you tread water
when your ship sinks
in the middle of the sea.
Not because you have a realistic
chance of being rescued,
but because everyone
who was ever
rescued treaded water
until help arrived, right?
It's the necessary, insufficient
precondition for survival,
is hope.
And so it's a hopeful book.
It's a book that implies that if
the situation seems intractably
difficult, but you can find one
way to make it a little better,
that from there, you
might find another way.
And I think that's a much better
message than the message that
says that when disaster strikes,
your neighbors are coming over
with a shotgun, and so you're
a sucker if you go over
to their house with
a covered dish.
And in that regard, like
a lot of science fiction,
it's not just a pulp story to
help you traverse the long slog
from the cradle to the grave,
but it's also an intervention
in the world that
I hope plays out
in some meaningful
way in people's lives.
So with that, I'll
take your questions.
Long rambling
statements followed
by "what do you think of that"
are technically questions,
but they're not good ones.
Anyone have a question?
Yeah, go ahead.
Are we recording these
and need to use the mic?
SPEAKER: Yeah-- [INAUDIBLE].
CORY DOCTOROW: All right.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So I have
quite a naive question.
I'm very familiar reading
books, but it's always
been a bit of a mystery
of how to write the book.
And maybe you can
describe your process?
So is it--
I mean, set the alarm
clock and get up at eight
and start typing, or what are
the phases you go through?
CORY DOCTOROW: I get
up at 8:00 on the days
I don't set the alarm.
I get up at 5:00.
How do you write a book?
So there's an
aphorism about book
writing that every
book teaches you
to write the book
you've just written,
and there's definitely
something to that.
I'm a great believer in
separating composition
from revision.
That I think,
premature optimization,
premature refactoring is a huge
crisis in prose composition.
That it can really confound
your ability to work.
I think that one of the
great mysteries of fiction
is why fiction is interesting.
And this plays into both
reading and writing stories,
because by definition, nothing
that happens in a book matters,
right?
None of the people in
this book are real.
So none of the things that
happen to them matter.
The most tragic death you've
ever read in literature,
you know, the death of
Romeo and Juliet-- spoiler,
they do die at the end--
that death is like, less
tragic than the death
of the yogurt culture you
digested with breakfast
this morning because the
yogurt was actually alive
and now it's dead.
Where as Romeo and
Juliet never lived.
So there's this weird
thing that happens
when we read a book we
have this limbic response.
We like cry.
We laugh.
We have this overall kind
of emotional involuntary
experience.
And I think the reason that
happens is that the way we
experience empathy for other
people, more generally,
is that when you first
get a piece of fragmentary
information about a person--
it can be seeing that person,
it could be hearing about them--
you start to build up a model.
And you revise that model
as new information comes in,
and you use that model
as a predictive tool
to understand whether
you can trust someone,
whether you want to
play with that person,
do stuff with that
person, whether they're
your enemy or your friend.
And that it's by
imagining the things that
happen to the
person, by imagining
them happening to the model,
that we experience empathy
for them.
So you hear about someone
who broke their leg.
You break the leg of a model.
You imagine how the model
would feel about it,
then you feel that feeling.
That's our interpretive process.
And I think when we read, we
build up models of people,
and then we subject them to
the traumas of the literature
and we feel empathy for them.
I think it's an optical illusion
for our empathy, reading.
But there's a
corollary in writing
because when you start writing,
it can be embarrassing.
It's like you're doing a
puppet show for yourself.
Like, hey, guys,
let's go on a quest.
That sounds great, here we go.
And it feels super artificial.
It feels like you
are making up stuff.
It feels like artifice.
But then there's
a point at which
the story kind of-- the
engine catches and it
starts to plot itself through
a largely unconscious process.
And that's really
important at novel-lengths
because generally, the moving
parts in a novel-length novel
are more than you could
consciously hold in your head
at any given time.
There's a lot of intuitive
work that goes on there.
And I think that the
way that that happens
is exactly the same
process as reading.
So I knew a guy at summer
camp, when I was about 14,
who had started having seizures
when he was about two years old
and already had profound
brain damage when I met him.
And I knew him at
the end of his life.
And in a last ditch
effort to save his life
and stop the seizures
from spreading
from one hemisphere of
his brain to the other,
they severed his
corpus callosum, right?
And so this is the
bundle of nerves
that join the two
hemispheres of your brain.
So now the two
hemispheres of his brain
became non-routable
to one another.
And this has this really
interesting effect,
in addition to being sort
of grisly and terrible--
you could hold something up
and if he saw it with one eye,
he could tell you what it was,
but not what it was called.
And if he saw it
with the other eye,
he could tell you what it was
called, but not what it was.
But here's the cool
part-- when he said it,
because both of his ears
heard it, he then knew.
He had created a free
space, acoustic link that
was this very
slow-high latency bus
to replace the extremely
high-low latency electric bus
that normally join the two
hemispheres of his brain.
I think when you
write, you have words
show up on the
screen that are words
that you are
consciously thinking of.
But then, they are routed
to the part of your brain
that automatically,
involuntarily
takes input from the
environment and uses
it to build models of people.
And in these two normally
non-routable parts
of your brain, start to
interact with each other.
And as you put the
words down, you
start to get insight,
without conscious effort,
into what the characters
are going to do.
And like, from a Claude Shannon
perspective, it makes no sense.
Like, you're basically
making information
where no information exists.
I think it's
basically signal loss
is turning into information.
It's just noise that you
interpret as information.
You're basically breathing
your own farts, right?
So this is the amazing thing
is when you start writing,
if you stay at it
long enough, then
the story starts to tell itself.
But when you go
back and refactor,
which is this hugely
compelling temptation
because you are a Wile E. Coyote
and you've run off the cliff
edge at this point.
You're no longer consciously
in control of the whole thing,
and some part of you
knows that it's not there,
and you want to
retreat to the safety
of the edge of the cliff.
And if you do that,
what you do is
you remind this
part of your brain
that's automatically
and voluntarily creating
the model that's helping
you write the book that it's
been on a fool's errand.
That there is no person there,
like one of those internet
hoaxes about a kid
who's dying of cancer
and you get all these
heart-rending letters
from the kid, and then
it all just turns out
to be this like
dude in Topeka who's
been like pretending to be
the kid for all the years.
It's one of those, right?
And then you're like, oh, I
got a scratch out the model.
Well, then you're
back to a puppet show.
So one of the things I
do is I don't revise.
I write every day.
I used to write
seven days a week.
When I became a
father, I made it five.
And I pick a word count to
write that day, every day--
a standard unit of work that
reflects the other stuff going
on in my life.
The minimum is about
a page, so 250 words.
The most I've ever done
is eight pages a day--
2,000 words a day.
And when I start when I
hit the limit, I stop.
And I stop mid-sentence.
That lets you write two or
three words the next day
without having to be creative.
It's like parking a
manual transmission
on a downhill slope.
Like, it'll roll itself into
gear before you start writing.
The heuristic for plotting,
especially a pulp novel,
is you have a person in a
place with a problem who's
trying intelligently
to solve it,
failing through no
fault of their own,
such that things get worse.
We are a nosy species.
We like to watch other
people solve their problems.
If you believe in
unfalsifiable hypotheses
from evolutionary
biology, maybe that's
because it lets us get a preview
into what strategies might work
if we experience that problem.
But it's definitely
a thing, that humans
find it hard to look
away from someone who's
solving a problem, especially
if they're just plausibly trying
to solve a problem, and it's not
clear what the outcome will be.
When they fail to
solve the problem
and the problem
gets worse, you have
rising tension, rising stakes,
and a new problem for them
to solve.
If you do that long enough,
eventually the stakes
reach a limit, and
that's a climax.
And then you write a
little bit afterwards
called the denouement, which
is kind of the settling
down period at the end.
And then you're done, right?
That's a novel.
And so that's the way that
you can heuristically write
a couple of pages every day.
Refactoring at the
end is a combination
of a lot of different things.
One is an editorial
note from your editor
who tells you about stuff.
One is going through.
I leave myself notes
in the manuscript.
Go back and fix this
later, in square brackets.
You go back and fix that stuff.
Using those notes rather
than stopping to do it.
And especially, using it
rather than researching.
Like, you know when you
have someone standing
at the end of the Brooklyn
Bridge, and you want to write,
he contemplated the Brooklyn
Bridge, all TK feet of it.
All blank feet of it.
You can go to Wikipedia
and look that up.
That's one Google query.
But then you will end up
in a Wikipedia click trance
that you might not emerge
from for half a day.
And so writing TK, it just
keeps you in the zone.
So you go back, you
fix all of that stuff.
You get an editorial note.
You fix anything you've
left yourself notes on.
And then with this
one, I did something
that was really about practice
that I'd evolved through some
of the internet stuff I do.
So I have glibness privilege.
I'm good at putting
words together.
My sentences read really nicely,
usually on the first pass.
I don't do a lot of line
editing when I write.
And what I'd worked out
is that over the years,
I'd spent a lot
of time just sort
of making my sentences shinier.
And if you're pretty
good already at that
and you work really
hard at it, you
might get from like 95%
proficiency to 95.5%
proficiency.
And when I was done
with this book,
I had been, in the interim,
using Twitter a lot.
And also, we had changed the
way that we did article displays
on Boing Boing.
We started doing leads in and
breaks with click-throughs,
which in the early days of
blogging, you never did, right?
It was all full
post on the page.
So I had to start writing these
super compact summaries that
would go above the fold.
So between tweeting and
that, I got really good
not just at sentences that read
well, but sentences that where
as compact as possible.
So when I was done
with this book,
every day for about a month,
I took 5,000 words out
of the book, put them in
a new text editor window--
I just write in gedit on Ubuntu.
It's just Emacs keybindings,
plain text editor.
And I went through and I nuked
1,000 words out of the 5,000
words on a sentence-by-sentence
basis until it was super tight.
And I cut like 20% of
the length of the book
without making a single
substantive edit.
It was all at the
line-edit level.
And I realized that
if you take something
that you're, like,
20% proficient at,
and you work really
hard at it over a book,
you can go to 50% proficient.
That there's so
many dividends to be
paid at enduring the kind
of like less emotionally
satisfying work of doing
something you're really
good at, and instead focusing
your attention on things
that you kind of suck at.
And that produced this
spectacular dividend
that, I think, made
this book a better book.
And the new book I'm
writing is even tighter.
And it's coming out
tight as I write it,
because that's what happens
when you get good at stuff
is you don't have to
think about it anymore.
It becomes just a thing
that happens automatically.
So let's see--
all of that stuff.
I want to say there is
another important composition
note in there.
So yeah, I write every day.
I write wherever I happen to be.
When it's a small chunk, you can
kind of do it wherever you are.
I wrote today's
chunk of the book
I'm working on in
the Lyft over here.
I wrote the sequel
to "Little Brother,"
I wrote "Homeland"
while touring Germany.
And I would go to like, four
gymnasiums-- high schools--
a day, and then do a
bookstore in the evening.
And I was touring
with my translator,
so he would read in
German for half an hour
and I'd read in English
for half an hour.
And I'd sit next to him on the
stage while he read in German.
Well, first of all, all the
kids spoke better English
than I did because they go
through the German education
system.
But also, I not only had already
heard him read this in German
and didn't speak German,
but I'd heard him
read it three times that day.
So I started writing the
sequel to "Little Brother"
on the stage.
Which at first, I was like,
is that going to be rude?
But then the kids would
go like, (GERMAN ACCENT)
hey, Doctor-professor
Doctorow, what are you
doing on the stage?
And I would say, well,
I'm writing is equal
to "Little Brother."
And they'd go, (GERMAN
ACCENT) Oh, it's so cool.
And so once you have
the method down,
you can kind of do
it wherever you are.
And at 2,000 words a
day, I wrote that book
in six weeks, which was
six weeks well-spent--
a little exhausting, but
six weeks well-spent.
Any other questions?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I have a
process question in regard
to writing for different media.
On your blog, you talked about
writing for some of the Disney
ghost-post assets
within a story box
that were sort of in-universe.
So how do you approach writing
an in-universe artifact rather
than, like, traditional prose?
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah,
writing the ghost-post stuff
was really interesting.
So for those of
you who don't know,
Disney R&D decided to
experiment with Loot Crates,
where you get a
subscription to merchandise
that comes every month.
And they wanted to do
them with a story that
ran through them, so like
a series of Loot Crates
with a story that ran through
them with custom bespoke,
low-run, limited edition
merchandise in them
that was related to some
Disney franchise or another.
And they prototyped it
with The Haunted Mansion.
They did 999 of them.
And I was the lead writer.
There was one
other writer on it.
And so the assets that I wrote--
it's was much more
like show writing.
So I worked in Imagineering
off and on as a contractor.
And show writing, it's stuff
like writing the signs,
writing the recorded
announcements.
Like if you've been
on the Jungle Boat
Cruise, the announcer who
speaks between the songs that
is supposed to be in
the 1930s, a radio
DJ in the 1930s telling you
about the riverboat cruise.
And so those assets, it's a
different kind of writing.
I wrote a couple of newspapers.
I wrote a ton of classified ads.
I wrote letters.
I wrote radio plays.
And they had these
formal characteristics,
which is that they all had to
tell this overarching story
that was a mystery.
And so there were elements that
couldn't be revealed in them.
There were things that
had to be held back
and they had to be
subsequently revealed.
And you had to have a sense
of how they all went together.
And I had a really
good project manager
on it, this woman,
Sarah Thatcher,
who put it all together.
Oh, and incidentally, I'm
allowed to tell you this,
unlike all of the
other work I've
ever done for Disney, because it
won Themed Entertainment Award,
and they put all the
contractors names on it,
so it released me from
my non-disclosure.
So I can tell you
I worked on this.
And so Sarah had
great spreadsheets
of what information needed to be
conveyed in different contexts.
And then in terms of the canon--
so first of all, I'm a
giant Haunted Mansion nut.
I was bitten by
radioactive Haunted Mansion
when I was 16 years old.
And so I know a lot of
the canon in my head,
but then all of that
stuff is on wikia, right?
Like the Disney Wikia Haunted
Mansion fandom is hardcore,
and they have resolved
all the canon.
And they've also,
like, marked out where
they're irreconcilable,
mutually non-routable canon,
like the Kitchen Sink comic
books versus the Marvel comic
books versus the thing--
there was a thing that the cast
members, the Haunted Mansion
employees in Florida
used to have,
called The Ghost Gallery, which
was just a three-ring binder
full of lore they'd written.
And that's found its way
online, some of which has been
formalized and some
of which hasn't.
Like a lot of the names of
the ghosts in the ride were
actually made up by cast members
and written down in the lore,
and then passed down into
the Kitchen Sink Press comics
and the movie with Wallace
Shawn and Eddie Murphy--
which was a terrible
movie, unfortunately--
and what have you.
So I would sit down
and say, OK, this
has this formal thing it
needs to do, which is rare
in a novel.
Novels are way
less purpose-built.
They're way less like,
this is a carburetor
and it does this thing, and
if it doesn't do this thing,
then it is not
serving its purpose.
And if it does anything
more than this thing,
then we should take
that other thing out
and put it into another
part that's machined for it.
It's not like
modular code, right?
It's a lot more blended,
a lot more kind of
federated and
inter-twingled than that.
But in this case, everything
had a clean purpose.
And so once I served that
purpose, I could really play.
And moreover, I could--
because I knew with the
whole structure was,
I could add elements
that I knew I could pick
up later in other elements.
So it was fun.
It was a lot more like writing
an ARG, I think, would be.
I've never done any ARG-writing.
But I think that's
what it would be like.
AUDIENCE: It is.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah,
is that what it's like?
Yeah, I think with
ARGs, the difference
is that with ARGs,
you get to play
with the players theories, the
fan theories, and wrap them in.
So when I talk--
like Maureen McHugh
talks about this with I
Love Bees, that they
had code fragments.
And the users inferred a Turing
complete programming language
from the code fragments,
which they then
used to write all their
remaining code fragments.
So they just threw
in some garbage code
and then the users inferred the
entire programming environment.
Any other questions?
Heath?
AUDIENCE: So the
last year has been,
depending on how you look at
it, either a really good year
for disasters, or
a really bad year.
Most recently, we've had
Texas we have Florida,
other places around the world.
And LA, depending on
how you look at it,
is a really good city
for disasters, also.
We've got fire, we've got mud.
We've got the earthquakes.
You've lived here,
now, a couple of years.
How has LA fit into your
writing or your storytelling
at all, if it has?
And what do you think the
future, optimistic or otherwise
is, for where we are right now?
CORY DOCTOROW: Wow, well, so
I had written a bunch of stuff
that's set in and
around LA, especially
in the San Fernando Valley.
I find it really
fascinating around there.
It's such a poster child
for different kinds
of ambitious Americanism--
car culture, Lockheed Martin.
It's where you go to
live the American dream
and have a big house.
Burbank is this really
weird city in that it's
like completely run by itself.
It's not part of the city of
LA, although it's in LA county.
And it's the spectacularly
well-run city where all
the services are like--
it's like being in like an
episode of "Father Knows Best."
The fire department is full
of friendly efficient dudes,
and so is the water and
power department, and so
are their garbage men,
and are the schools.
And the houses all
look like b-roll
from "Father Knows
Best," because that's
where they shot the b-roll
for "Father Knows Best," so
thinking about how that
lives in the 21st century
has been really interesting.
I just wrote a ton of
stuff for a TV pitch
that a studio put
together with Alex Gibney,
about machine learning
and its future.
And I wrote these fiction
sequences where I set it
all in the San Fernando Valley.
And it was about things like
the future self-driving cars
in a place that's designed
around the automobile
and the future of
work automation
in a place where all of
the white collar jobs
are super automatable.
They're things like
insurance adjuster
and a bunch of
low-level health stuff,
like that we have
these giant health
centers where 85% of the
stuff that's done there
is super routinized.
And it's just such
a ground zero for it
and such ground zero
for weird politics,
where there are these--
although LA, as a city,
a coastal city in the US,
is pretty blue--
the San Fernando Valley
is full of some deep red.
And so you know what
does that look like?
And what does austerity
look like in a city
that doesn't have it?
And because it's also a
cheap place and an edge city,
it's full of people
who have less money.
So it's much more diverse
than you'd expect, as well.
And then the last
thing that it has,
that I think all of
LA benefits from,
is the upside of sprawl,
which is that sprawl means
that somewhere
that you can reach,
there is a storefront
that is for rent
so cheaply, that no idea how
matter how weird or dumb it is,
can't get a shot.
Whereas like New
York, it's like there
are three kinds of businesses
that you can have in New York--
there's a bodega, there is a
CVS, and there's a bank, right?
And it's like the
recycled backgrounds
of "Flintstones" cartoons
now, walking through midtown--
just the same five stores
over and over and over again.
Whereas if you've lived
in LA for any time,
you know that every neighborhood
gets a sushi joint that
would have a Michelin
star in a strip
mall between a vaping store
and a Mail Boxes Et Cetera
that just the locals know about.
And so that is the
plus and minus.
In terms of the future
of LA, I don't know.
I mean, we're looking to
buy a house in Burbank,
and LA being in the midst
of the same housing bubble
that all the great cities are in
the middle of, we keep getting
outbid.
So we're driving around to
a house viewing this summer,
and my wife, who's
British, says, so
what's the earthquake
stuff like in Burbank?
We're like away from the main
part of the earthquakes, right?
I'm like, well,
let's have a look.
So I Google it.
We are, like, on the San Andreas
fault. That's in our house,
right?
And then there's like three
more immediately next to us.
And you kind of just got
to take them at their word.
I moved to San Francisco
right after Loma Prieta,
when all of the
retrofitting was going
on in the middle of
the dotcom bubble.
So every dotcom was renting
spectacularly expensive
real estate in a building that
was a construction zone where
they were putting
up cantilevered Xs
the entire length of it, that
no one knew whether they'd work.
And I think we still don't know
whether they'll work, right?
I think a lot of The Big
One seismic retrofitting
is based on super
theoretical models.
And even when we
test those models,
we make assumptions about
the material properties
of older buildings that
are really unwarranted.
We say, well, that's a
wooden building built
with timbers in 1925.
We know what the
properties of those are.
But we are assuming a
perfectly spherical cow
of uniform density on
a frictionless surface.
They did not have uniform
building inspection in 1925.
They used bubble gum and spit
just like everybody else.
And so even though we go,
oh, that's been brought up
to code with seismic
retrofitting,
the assumptions about
the underlying materials
and construction
techniques are--
we all know that they're
totally unwarranted.
We know that if you
ripped up the drywall,
you'd find studs that were just
not nailed to anything, just
sitting there.
That someone was like, eh.
I mean, we've all
been there, right?
So I don't know.
I don't know what the
hell's going to happen
when The Big One comes.
It scares the shit out of me.
And we just had a huge fire
in Burbank where we all
had to stay indoors.
The one thing I do hope is that
given how collegial Burbank is,
and it is--
our neighborhood is super
walkable and it's full
of people who know each other--
that the resilience is
there in time of crisis.
Like, Bug Out Bags are
for cowards, right?
Like, if your first
reaction to the disaster
is to run for the hills,
the one thing we know
is that you will not contribute
to the recovery, right?
If the lights go out and
you run to the hills,
you will not be a
party to the Turning
the Lights Back On Project.
You're going to be
waiting in the hills
while other people
sort your shit out,
and then coming back and
going, hey, what did I miss?
And so Burbank is full of people
who I have kind of weak ties
with, who I feel like I could
ring their doorbell and say,
our freezer's knocked out so
we're smoking all the meat.
Do you want to come
over for a barbecue?
And that's, I
think, the best hope
we have of surviving a crisis.
Any other questions?
How we doing for time?
[? HEATH ROE: ?] We've got time
for more questions if you guys
have them.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
I'm told that if
we finish early,
I get to fly home
in Larry's jet, so.
Nope?
All right, then--
well, if any of you
would like to bring
your books up,
and if anyone has a writing
implement I can borrow,
because that's one
thing I forgot,
I'd be happy to
deface your books.
[APPLAUSE]